[Music]
instant noodles more than 100 billion
servings were slurped up around the
world last year that's more than 13
servings for every person on the planet
so you've almost certainly eaten them
but have you ever thought about why they
seem to be everywhere instant noodles
are one of the world's most successful
industrial foods they're cheap to make
and cheap to buy making them a global
phenomenon they've been eaten at the top
of Everest astronauts have carried them
into space and they've even become the
most traded legal item in US prisons
more about that later so how did this
simple but revolutionary food come about
let's go back to Japan just after the
Second World War large parts had been
destroyed by bombing much of the
population was going hungry
a feisty entrepreneur mama fuku Ando was
penniless after a failed business
venture he wanted to reinvent himself
and he had an idea when he spotted long
lines of Japanese people shivering in
the cold waiting for a hot bowl of
traditional ramen noodles Ando knew the
Japanese government was looking for ways
to encourage his people to eat the food
aid given to Japan by the US government
oil and wheat flour so he disappeared
into a wooden pot in his back garden for
a year and when he emerged he created
instant noodles they were instantly
popular and they fueled Japan's modern
economic rise feeding students and also
hungry workers they soon caught on
elsewhere maybe because they're the
ultimate hot blank slate they can be
adapted to fit anyone's taste buds in
Thailand green curry flavors a hit in
Mexico they're eaten with limes and
salsa in Japan you could try chicken
nugget and fries flavored noodles or in
Pakistan pizza flavor environmentalists
aren't so happy about the noodles
seemingly endless spread they're made
with palm oil which contributes to
deforestation in countries like
Indonesia and most noodles come with
lots of
stick packaging but quick foods like
instant noodles are lifesavers in
emergency situations like earthquakes or
for anyone who needs the comfort of a
hot meal without access to a kitchen
shrinking prison food budgets in the
u.s. mean the prisoners are turning to
instant noodles the cheapest item on
sale in prison stores to fill their
stomachs they're also getting creative
grinding down noodles and water into a
paste that can be shaped into makeshift
pizza bases using crushed ramen
prisoners make their own versions of
burritos sandwiches even a dish called
coke ramen made with instant noodles and
you guessed it and of course cup noodles
are responsible for powering millions
and millions of late-night study
sessions from a hot in Japan to grocery
stores around the world they may only
take two minutes to spring into action
but next time you're cooking them think
about the eternal life of the instant
noodle
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon